y usted que va a ser el reto que tiene a
nivel de imagen ahora el nuevo rey
carlos junto con la reina con la reina
consult y camila parker bush un reto a
nivel de imagen después de venir de una
reina la reina se ve segunda su madre
que era extremadamente popular
da de la remesa de segunda es icónica va
a quedar ya los anales de la historia
totalmente
tiene un
un largo camino por delante para ganarse
el favor del pueblo británico es verdad
que desde hace pocos años podríamos
decir en la figura la imagen tanto del
príncipe carlos al rey carlos y de su
consorte de la reina consorte camila y
ahora mismo ha ido mejorando pero los
británicos son gran parte del pueblo
británico no perdonan a su nuevo rey ese
pasado con lady di con con la princesa
diana de gales
es verdad que el bueno pues se lleva
preparando desde hace
70 y 70 años que sólo se lleva su madre
reinando pero le va a costar le va a
costar el tener la aceptación que tenía
su madre la reina isabel segunda
yo digo insisto es que la reina es el
segundo muchisimos británicos que no han
conocido a otro monarca a otro soberano
es ahora el papel de carlos como nuevo
jefe de la casa real británica como
nuevo jefe de estado del estado del
reino unido
va a ser importante y elche tiene que
ganar la confianza el respeto y el
cariño de todo el pueblo británico
cariño respeto y confianza que sí que
tiene el ya nuevo heredero al trono
británico es el duque de cambridge es
que ya le nombraran príncipe de gales
señor merino profundicemos precisamente
en lo que supuso para el príncipe carlos
nuevo rey la muerte de lady di y su
divorcio toda esta polémica muy
recordada de los 90 que según la reina
fueron sus peores años
exactamente para la famosa frase del
annus horribilis fue la separación de
carlos y diana
también se habían separado el principio
de sarah ferguson se quemó el castillo
de windsor entonces es el escándalo de
lady di el escándalo de diana de gales o
de lady diana spencer fue un escándalo
sin precedentes en el reino unido-
conmocionó al todo pueda todo el pueblo
británico
y
diana de gales o diana spencer sí que
supo ganarse el favor y el cariño del
pueblo británico porque jugó muy bien
las bazas ella era su supo que era muy
bien su marca personal y ese
acercamiento a al pool británico al
pueblo de a pie cosa que la monarquía
británica de las familias miembros de la
familia real y técnica no estaban
acostumbrados para ellos es su estatus
hará mucho más elevado y ella es la que
reconduzca conduzco eso es ese
acercamiento y es ese hándicap que tiene
que tiene carlos el estar en contacto
con él con los ciudadanos de a pie el
saber lo que quieren